what are some common myths about horror
films I think they are too many probably
who movies they're like kind of done in
the same way or they should be done in
the same way following a recipe or a
certain concept or certain you know
because there are so many subgenres in
the hollow in the horror movies like you
know you have slashes and you have
zombies and people tend to kind of do
the same thing over and over again and I
think that's kind of kind of boring in
the same time nowadays there are people
reinventing the genre and that's
something I am more interested in doing
exploring other avenues and other ways
of doing things also probably people
think sometimes as Harnish is kind of
dumb kind of stupid or it's just you
know kill kill kill and that's all it is
but there's so many interesting movies
out there and nowadays people express
more things use the journal to express
more things and I think it's getting
interesting like hereditary didn't seem
like a full horror film at times it was
very fascinating was more about a family
and there was a still eeriness to it and
then at times horrific parts but I
really enjoyed that as someone who's not
a total consumer of horror alright well
I think people are trying to and they
should do different types of horror
movies and things that you know either
they are based on your personal
experiences or they there are things
that they find horrific because I don't
think they're limits and I think
everybody should just try to do more
interesting things that come back again
and again with the same recipes for us
you know it's boring to do the same
thing
over and over again even if you know
because we make mostly horror movies so
you don't want to make the same movie
over and over again it is boring you
want to explore other things you know
that time sometimes it is fun too okay
you know this year I'm making a horror
movie but next year I'm making a zombie
movie but more than that sometimes you
do want to explore and create things
that you haven't done before or they
haven't been done before so when we're
doing high eight and high def Bret
directed segments for each as well we're
trying to see what we can do to
contribute to the genre and we realize
that the best thing to do is go to our
personal experiences and put them out
there so in height we did a segment
called a scout that explores a scout
that goes wrong but also the tension
between you know another director with
you know who's involved with a younger
actress age gap and past and present in
the desert because we wanted to I mean I
wanted to make a movie in the desert
brett has done that before and I thought
it's also an interesting backdrop for a
horror movie because it's harder to see
where the killer comes from because it's
such an open space and for me it's very
American and visually it's it's stunning
and for hi-def we decided to continue
with the filmmaking personal based
stories so we did a segment about an
audition that goes wrong and it's all
and we wrote it together it and this
happened before the meet to movement but
because you know we been working in the
industry for a while with there
witnessed or things that happen to us we
put them in the segments because you
know it's so much abuse in the industry
not only for women actually and I always
think we thought we should address that
of course the ignition goes tragically
wrong and horrific but we wanted to its
once again it's about what human beings
can do it to each other and it's about
pushing the limits of somebody who wants
to succeed to make it in the industry on
how much people can put up with abuse so
that's you know it's always all sorts of
interesting thing seems huge you know
you want explore we just unfortunately
you don't have the time or the money to
do as much as you like to do because
we've always have ideas that we wanna
explore explore scripts or you know
things ready to go did anybody get
squeamish about that it's interesting
because people seem to want to talk
about the me to movement in terms of
outing people but then when we talk
about it as a group I think a lot of
people kind of like don't want to go
there and it's interesting it's like an
elephant in the room and it exists but
then whether it's someone who's a
willing participant with it there's
definitely people male and female that
are well shot or they're an agreed upon
relationship yeah and they're okay with
that and it's just interesting how we
it's like we can't talk about it but
then we can out people on Twitter you
know it's it's a very strange I'm not
about necessarily about outing people
and nobody got squeamish I think we
should address certain things you know
because they do happen they happen to us
and they're not it's not so much sexual
but it's about human behavior you know
and how we treat each other and for me
coming from Romania that was also very
strange and weird to see how much abuse
was in the industry and how much sexism
I mean I didn't see sexual harassment
but I saw a lot of sexism and abuse
toward like I said all directors he was
so much abuse that I was shocked and I
think we should talk about that and you
know because people need to know it's
not all glamour in Hollywood here now
it's just
a lot of hard work and you do put up
with a lot of things in order to make a
movie sometimes sure and I gets to the
the stakes being so high and people want
so badly
oh yeah things that turn out whatever
part of the industry there yeah yeah and
you know when we're auditioning actors
for for this part we're talking to
actors and we're asking them you know
when they're reading and Aldama we're
like is it shocking for you what do you
think and they hoard everybody was
telling us no it's not shocking at all
we had have our own stories and this in
you know we're way since kind of real
because okay not all of the situations
there in the script happened to us but
similar things did happen here and there
and everybody had other stories and for
us we felt like we're doing the right
thing to show a slice of what is going
on in a more like in a fantasy world but
that we created but you know it's based
on reality and it starts real so it just
goes a bit in a fantasy world at some
point
you